wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
nico was machst du hier
ich bin hier weil ich sehen will wie war
dein termin bei der agentur für arbeit
sehr gut ich werde eine ausbildung zum m
[Musik]
wie ist es mit zwei raten mechatroniker
machen ich wäre eine ausbildung zum
zweiradmechaniker machen ich arbeite in
einer werkstatt und muster fahrräder und
motorräder reparieren also alles mit
zwei rädern
die ausbildung dauert drei jahre das
finde ich auch denn ich muss endlich
geld für dinge jetzt das zuerst muss ich
eine sprachprüfung bestehen und dann
kann ich die ausbildung beginnen das
schaffst du nie co jetzt sei doch mein
optimistisch so schwer ist sie prüfen
auch nicht lustig getroffen bereiten
ja ich weiß und was ist mit dir ich
möchte studieren aber ich weiß noch
nicht so genau was es gibt so viele
studienfächer
aber moment brauche ich vor allen dingen
einen job und suchst du schon
ich kann schlecht einen job suchen wir
nicht immer zu hause bleiben muss es
geht um deine zukunft komisch sagen
meine eltern auch
ich muss wieder nach oben
[Musik]
bis bald